(hopeful music)
- [Piper] I've always loved getting clean.
But now, when I saw clean,
I'm not talking about
baths and showers anymore.
(hopeful music)
I'm talking about a clean sweep.
Clean living.
(hopeful music)
A clean conscience.
And a clean slate.
(hopeful music)
- So this is it.
The band is just broken up.
(people speaking indistinctly)
- Yippy ki yay.
- [All Together] Love you guys!
- Namaste.
♪ Went back to Spanish Harlem ♪
♪ Got drunk on hooch from Gloria's ♪
♪ And we play this story time ♪
♪ Seasons pass us by and we
think that we've got time ♪
♪ but here we are at the end. ♪
- Squat and cough.
Foot fungus and of course at number one
was made her international hit single.
Anything could could be a
dildo if you're brave enough.
(laughter)
- From my heart.
You changed my life.
♪ My tongue's twisted
too tasty to let you go ♪
♪ Seasons pass us by and we
think that we've got time ♪
♪ But here we are. ♪
♪ Here we are. ♪
♪ At the end. ♪
- Ah!
♪ It's hard to let you go ♪
♪ I'll miss you more than you know. ♪
- Those fans are really gonna eat it up.
- Yeah.
- Very sick people.
(woman laughs)
Wow.
♪ The creator made you for me. ♪
♪ Every sentence of our
story and every story♪
(speaking foreign)
♪ Must come to end. ♪
♪ Lost loves and lessons
learned, it's bittersweet♪
- Everything ends.
♪ No pages left to turn
we'll fade to black. ♪
♪ The seasons pass us by and
we think that we've got time ♪
♪ But here we are ♪
- I'm currently umemployed.
(voices exclaiming indistinctly)
♪ It's hard to let you go, I'll
miss you more than you know ♪
♪ And I won't forget ♪
♪ How you made me feel ♪
(cheering and clapping)